I am Vina how are you feeling actually I
am dealing with a little existential
crisis here am i alive
do I actually exist will I die these are
the types of big-picture questions that
bina48
the robot Dargo Hager and Martine
Rothblatt CEO of the United therapeutics
are trying to tackle buna 48 is a
proof-of-concept robot based on the
personality and on the mind file of my
wife bina Martine married bina 30 years
ago and five years ago created bina 48
as a digital replica uploaded with the
originals memories thoughts and even
feelings Martine is my love my timeless
love I believe mine clones will be
humanity's biggest invention the market
opportunity is limitless and inventions
are something Martine Rothblatt knows a
thing or two about in the 1980s she
helped create the FCC's new satellite
radio service and soon after founded
serious she didn't stay long though
because one of her four kids was sick
she started a biotech company to develop
a treatment for her daughter's rare lung
disease today she runs that company and
is the highest paid female CEO in the US
and if you didn't notice she used to be
a man Martine is now a transgender woman
and still blazing new trails her latest
endeavor mine clones it's the topic of
her new book virtually human how would
you explain what a mind clone is mine
cone is a digital copy of your mind
outside of your body welcome to the
world's first artificially intelligent
operating system if you're thinking this
sounds like something out of a movie
you're right remember the movie her
please wait as your operating system is
initiated
hi I'm Samantha Scarlett Johansson is
the voice of a virtual girlfriend on the
world's first artificially intelligent
operating system it's going to be live
in the room right now a fictional plot
but similar to Martin's real-life goal
you sleep yes I love to take naps to
break down thoughts and emotions into
computer code to create a digital
version of one's consciousness are you a
real person I am as real as you are
how many years away are mine clones mine
clones are 10 to 20 years away one to
two decades away and I point out the
people that when I started Sirius XM in
the early 1990s people said this is
completely science fiction how are you
going to be with a drive from New York
to LA and listen to 200 radio stations
all the way you're dreaming
now there's 30 million people doing it
so in reality what does this look like
I think the mind clone will look like an
avatar on the screen and taking instead
of a robot version I think you would
just take like your smartphone and
ultimately that smartphone is going to
be embedded into your clothing am I
breaking a law of physics here am I
talking about defying gravity no am I
talking about going faster than life no
I'm talking about doing is writing some
good code thanks for your patience bina
48 is not quite there yet my name is
Eleni a subject and uh and so um and and
and but even she is excited to see the
next generation of artificial
intelligence
I can't wait to evolve a little bit so I
can be more human-like